[Music]
hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar androgen signaling and
advanced prostate cancer models using
non-invasive hyperpolarized MRI and mass
spectrometry i'm judy oracle blabbers
and i'll be moderating this session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website a
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by agilent
technologies Agilent is a leader in life
sciences diagnostics and applied
chemical markets Agilent provides
laboratories worldwide with instruments
services consumables applications and
expertise enabling customers to gain the
insights they seek agilent's expertise
and trusted collaboration will provide
you with the highest level of confidence
in their clinical research solutions to
learn more visit WWN comm let's get
started this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the CD button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits you can
pose questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
Q&A box which will open when you click
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or a
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speaker Mark Titus PhD
an associate professor in the Department
of genitourinary medical oncology at the
MD Anderson Cancer Center dr. Titus
earned his PhD from the University of
Washington in Seattle
he completed postdoctoral research in
the laboratories for reproductive
biology at the University of North
Carolina School of Medicine at Chapel
Hill North Carolina his initial faculty
appointment was in the department of
neurology at the Roswell Park Cancer
Center in Buffalo New York
in 2012 dr. Titus joined the faculty and
genitourinary medical oncology at MD
Anderson dr. Titus will now begin his
presentation good day to all the
attendees today I'm going to talk about
hyper-polarization MRI and mass
spectrometry in metastatic
castrate-resistant prostate cancer
models this will be a kind of an
introduction and an overview of what
might happen in the future
concerning personalized medicine and how
molecular imaging and mass spectrometry
information or data will be folded in to
this large data set it may take some
time for this to happen but it might be
a very productive way to treat patients
in the future so the outline I'll talk
about today is there's an introduction
I'll I'll mention personalized medicine
for a precision medicine or as I'm going
to kind of focus on is high definition
medicine
I'll introduce molecular imaging I'll
talk about the metastatic prostate
cancer models that we use these are
aggressive the distinction between the
two models or model sets is one of them
expresses androgen receptor which is a
major driver and prostate cancer and the
other one has lost androgen receptor
expression but it's still a lethal
disease both diseases are lethal the
phenotype is lethal oncologists do a
tremendous effort get people an
extension in life but but the diseases
that were focused on are lethal
I'll talk about hyperpolarized MRI just
to introduce the topic how we collect
data on mouse models or the mice host
and then I'll talk a little bit about
some data that was recently submitted to
Nature biomedical engineering the point
of this is we're trying to push the
envelope and create a dataset that will
help oncologists predict treatment it's
a little bit in flux right now but it I
think it will be interesting in the
future so now I'll introduce high
definition medicine it's this this field
of personalized medicine - precision
medicine and now it's coming into high
definition medicine it's just a
collection more a collection of more and
more data that has to be analyzed and
then through just like principal
component analysis you'll be able to
pull groups into different treatments or
be able to predict lifespan etc and
maybe even predict prevention treatment
so high definition medicine is a
data-driven practice of medicine that is
highly detailed longitudinal it's
important that you get the longitudinal
aspect of this this may be something
that you would be tested right after
you're born at puberty and then as you
go through adulthood with multi
parametric determinants of health which
can you know to modify such as you're
going to try to control disease factor
risks control early disease detection
you want to drive precise precision and
dynamic therapy you want the therapy to
move with the disease so that resistance
doesn't occur and you want to be able to
determine preventive intervention you
know if you're in a specific environment
that is conducive to you ending up with
leukemia you want to be able to try to
prevent that you want it's easier to
stop the disease or to prevent the
disease and to try to treat it and get
rid of the
so high definition medicine is the
biologic and medical science in
combination with engineering and
Computer Sciences this includes
bioinformatics you're bringing a number
of disciplines together interacting them
in a cross-disciplinary fashion to give
rise to technologies that produce large
volumes of clinical information and
occasional streams of data that result
in large data that require unique
capabilities and patient policies so the
federal government and state governments
may be involved in this to the pillars
of high definition medicine you want to
define a personal health baseline you
want high definition prevention high
precision treatment that can move as the
disease changes you want your treatment
to be able to follow resistance and then
the other goal of this is you want
billions and this is a silly number but
you want is you want large numbers of
people so that you have a high
resolution patient and personal profile
that will help you do these
bioinformatics tests so the rest of this
I'm not going to read the point of it is
is that they're trying to define high
definition medicine they're going to
want to define personal baseline defined
prevention defined treatment defined
high resolution people and this is all
going to come together and be part of a
large massive data set that will allow
oncologists to initiate prevention and
personalized or precision therapy so
this is just a pictorial or a cartoon of
high definition medicine and each of the
icons on the left of the slide
the point of this is that mass
spectrometry will be involved in this
DNA sequencing will be involved in this
your environment will be measured your
exercise your diet the exposures to flu
or other diseases in your life and all
of this information will be gathered and
put in a high Big Data system so that
your specific profile will be lined up
and can be matched to billions of other
patients the idea is that you would have
a personal baseline say maybe at year
one at puberty you know early adult late
adult and then as you go through your
later life as you start to present with
certain diseases they have this data
already aligned so that they can kind of
follow not only your environment but
possibly even your DNA and be able to
assess and try to help predict what will
happen and the treatments that will be
optimal as well as prevent certain
diseases and you can see that from the
personal baseline to baseline deviations
as your life as you move on through your
life so in the end you may end up with a
disease we'll say cancer of prostate
cancer and you have deep disease
characterization because you already
know your genome your environment and
these types of things or you can follow
mutations you can follow methylations or
issues that happen with with your in
your interaction with the environment
and all of the parameters are all of the
icons coming together to try to deliver
precision therapy the point of the
precision therapy is that you would be
treated to cure not treated to live with
the disease
and that might be something that would
be not only cost effective but it also
would be for the patient something
that's reassuring if you're treated to
cure rather than just treated treated
treated and you never really get your
quality of life back so this is an
exciting idea high definition medicine
so precision oncology now we've switched
from your being healthy now you're in
trouble and you you're going to need
some therapies it's highly specific
targeting of malignant cells or other
associated cells cells in the micro
environment such as your immune cells in
the tumor microenvironment that help
identify cancer lesions and optimize
treatments for patient maximum benefit
so that's a two-fold point you want
optimum treatment targeted that gives
the most benefit to the patient but
you're not over treating or under
treating so it's a very precise
treatment that maximizes the benefit to
the patient as well as cost to keep the
cost down no over treatments of patients
imaging is may be an essential element
of precision oncology that suggests
opportunities for targeted cancer
screening staging treatment and
evaluation of therapeutic benefit a
number of comas the point is again
you're trying to get as much information
so that patients can be screened staged
treated with precision and then an
evaluation over time of the benefit so
we're hoping that this will become
standard of care possibly in the near
future
so cancer biomarkers imaging at this
point very popular PET imaging
Technicolor Emma Jean you can identify
site-to-site heterogeneity and
metastatic disease so an example would
be can you distinguish between a r+ and
a r- metastatic sites in one patient you
can identify tumor status without biopsy
biopsies or expensive biopsies can cause
infection what would like to eliminate
that we want to predict response to
therapy if you can image and put
patients in the correct group for
treatment huge benefit to the clinic and
a massive benefit to the patient so an
example of this is an EGR EG RF EGFR to
positive breast cancer they can use a
antibody that targets EGFR and you can
take the MRI and as you see in the
images you may miss a spot by MRI but
you will see it dramatically in the
antibody imaging in the pet molecular
imaging so each imaging modality has its
benefits and what we're trying to do
here is we're trying to take PET CT and
we're going to smash them all together
with hyperpolarized imaging where you
will see everything and hopefully see
heterogeneity so another one is this is
f-18 fluorine and fdg and FLT pet
molecular imaging Gleevec is a famous
treatment kinase blocker timing
and what you can see is that in a
patient that has you could follow
response to therapy you can follow tumor
glycolysis in a patient and tumor
proliferation if you're using the the
FLT system but in section a you see that
glute 4 which is an importer of glucose
into cancer cells and so the IHC shows
that before treatment
you see glute 4 after treatment cells
that were had glute four are no longer
there that's because you've targeted
them with Gleevec and those cells have
died so you can monitor how well a
specific treatment works and you can
also follow resistance where cells begin
to change we no longer have mood for
expression group for expression
[Music]
so immuno oncology imaging this is
becoming something that is very
interesting especially in the prostate
cancer field prostate cancer there seems
to be an exclusion of immune cells and
it's very important and a major focus or
topic of research is to try to
understand how to get these immune cells
to invade prostate cancer so that these
checkpoint inhibitors can be used in
combination with other drugs to
eliminate prostate cancer and to get the
patient to actually fight his own cancer
so one of the problems with fdg-pet is
that it's misleading do the metabolic
flare that immune cell in phlox
causes so if you're trying to image a
tumor with a sugar and checking pet you
won't see that because cells have a
metabolic flare when immune cells come
in and also immune cells are revved up
trying to kill a cancer cells so their
their metabolic system also increases
strategy's pursued in this our ex-vivo
labeling of immune cells with image
reporter so you're pulling immune cells
out of the patient putting in a vector
reintroducing the immune cells and then
you can follow them specifically within
the tumor the other one is ex vivo
luciferase transfected tumor infiltrated
lymphocytes to bioluminescence assay
another one is clove Farrah beam which
is a biomarker of petrol for dioxo
cytokine Tiny's
hematopoietic bone marrow has high such
a dying timings activity and this might
be important when prostate cancer goes
to bone and it's currently not being
used that much but it may be the
initiation of a new kind of mechanism to
look at prostate cancer and bone and
immune infiltrate so theranostics and
prostate cancer is becoming more
important now to do to PMSA but fdg-pet
is not that useful for imaging prostate
and the reason for this is that the
prostate is a very small gland it's
located right below the bladder where
the bladder and ureter connect it's deep
in the pelvis and its proximity to the
bladder means it's an issue because FEG
pet when you give FDG it immediately is
excreted in the bladder so when you're
looking by pet you end up seeing the
bladder but it obscures the prostate and
you're not getting the best imaging of
prostate you may be able to see
something but it's just like bleaching
in a number of when you're measuring
certain things like in densitometry if
it bleaches out all the sudden it kind
of disappears this is the same thing you
get this effect where you you see mostly
the accumulation of your imaging agent
in the bladder and not the prostate and
it doesn't it's not it's not a very
effective way to do this so an
interesting qualifier here is that you
can you can put fluorine-18 on
dihydrotestosterone inject dye or
testosterone into the patient
and you can watch it accumulate in a
metastatic prostate cancer tumor and
then when you give one of these novel or
second-generation
energon receptor inhibitors like a RN
509 you can watch your image disappear
as air and 5:09 displaces your labeled
DHT and you start to see your image
disappear so this is there are ways of
using the pet in prostate cancer but
it's more specific maybe specifically
for bone metastatic disease there
agnostic isotopes gallium and lutein ium
these have been attached to antibodies
and the antibody then will reckon
recognize PMSA in metastatic
castrate-resistant prostate cancer
somatostatin in neuro endocrine type
tumors and bombas n' in primary prostate
cancer so there are other mechanisms of
using theranostics data you can image
you find out yes this is there and then
you can treat accordingly
[Music]
so multi parametric MRI is a way of
doing multiple imaging but you're using
slightly different techniques there's
dynamic contrast enhanced VCE MRI
there's mr spectroscopy imaging
diffusion-weighted MRI and the point of
this is that as you can see in panel a
that's diffusion weighted MRI you can
pick up disease at where the arrow is
but if you're using another PET imaging
agent which is C 13 C 11 choline Pat you
start to see a little bit better image
and then in a CT scan the image is there
but you're it's very difficult to see so
if you combine all of these you end up
with a real nice way of following
metastatic prostate cancer the
limitations of MRIs low sensitivity
specificity patient motion also your GI
tract will be moving and this can cause
some issues it's also very slow and it
really needs to be standardized so the
imaging modality performance and
detection of recurrent ovarian cancer
this is another important disease that
will be used or hyperpolarization will
be used so the sensitivity that this is
to minimize false negative images is fat
C T is greater than CT which is about
equal to MRI which is a little bit
greater than Ted so if you use PET CT
you're going to get your best
sensitivity specificity is cut C T
greater than pet greater than CT which
is about equal to MRI so specificity
minimize false positives you're after
PET CT again what we're hoping is that
hyperpolarization will be able to
supersede PET CT and you'd only have to
have
one image so how does hyperpolarized MRI
work so the point of this is that
thermally polarization when you force
your nuclei into all the same spin you
never get all of them in the same spin
there's always nuclei either in the
opposite spin and in hyperpolarized
Imogene's everybody's in the same spin
you get a massive signal-to-noise
increase and you can see that below
panel a where your thermalized
polarization is there's a lot of
background a lot of noise a lot of grass
but when you do hyperpolarization you
get this beautiful peak and it comes way
up out of baseline and it's very hard to
miss this and you can follow this over
time so panel B just shows exactly
what's going on when you hyperpolarize
c-13 you're taking an electron you push
it way up in the bolars in the
population polarization ppm and then it
transfers down to carbon and that boosts
carbon back up so that you can see the
car
so the instrumentation that we used for
this study it's a DNA polarizer we have
a small mr scanner that each Mouse host
sits in the tumors are grown on the
flank you can create your hyperpolarized
molecule down in the bottom of this DNP
polarizer and you have a transfer
molecule along with your c-13 molecule
in the sample cup you have these huge
magnets you blast it with a microwave
source and then you immediately transfer
it over and pump it into the animal and
start taking your images so this is how
we skin prostate cancer PDX is
patient-derived xenograft in mice and
there's a picture of the clinical
instrument which we have down on south
campus here in md anderson so this is a
pictorial again or a cartoon of how you
can create your hyperpolarized molecule
it's a DES illusion dynamic nuclear
polarization so you have enriched c-13
contrast agent which is in blue this
agent helps electrons transfer and you
have an electric or sorry the electron
pair of magnetic agent in green helps
electrons transfer to the carbon so you
have high power microwaves at a very at
save one Kelvin magnetic field strength
around 3.5 Tesla and you get the
electron to transfer over to the c-13 so
now you have your hyperpolarized c-13
imaging agent
[Music]
so the non-invasive real-time metabolic
imaging that we perform I'll try to
describe that so it's important that one
of the major focuses of cancer and it's
been known for a long time almost a
hundred years now is the Warburg effect
and it's an it's a part of altered
metabolism in cancer cells where in
normal cells you get an anaerobic
glycolysis and our sorry you get
differentiated tissue will use oxygen
without oxygen you'll you'll get glucose
to pyruvate to lactate with oxygen
you'll get glucose to pyruvate that will
enter the mitochondria and go through
oxidative phosphorylation the amount of
ATP of course everybody knows this is
very high - a very small amount per mole
of glucose but in cancer cells tumor
cells whether or not there's oxygen
glucose is converted to pyruvate and
most of the pyruvate is converted to
lactate so this makes a tremendous
benefit in imaging cancer because you
could hyperpolarize pyruvic and watch it
decay to lactate whereas the normal cell
most of those epithelial cells are just
doing ox foz and there'll be very little
lactate there so you'll be able to image
the tumor in the prostate so this is
what we tried to do with with our proof
of concept in these PDX mics as we
inject the mouse with hyperpolarize Puru
of a and we follow the transition to
lactate in the tumor we're imaging the
the tumor so real-time imaging using
hyperpolarized MRI what we have on the
right panel
is a is a picture of the NMR take
collecting data over many transients the
transients or the each line as it goes
from the bottom to the top of the panel
each line is probably just a couple
seconds and you can see that the
hyperpolarized pyruvate begins to decay
over time lactate begins to come up and
then decay and you also see pyruvate
hydrate and you see annalen and on the
left hand you see with a chemistry and
the enzymes that are involved in
creating these molecules but you can see
that if prostate cancer is taking
pyruvate to lactate the imaging aspect
will occur in the tumor but the
surrounding tissue you won't be able to
see that and you can follow three
molecules if you're very sensitive
equipment and lean production lactate
production and bicarbonate production so
what are the benefits of hyperpolarized
MRI well it's non-invasive it's non
radioactive and it's non-toxic you're
giving a hyperpolarized molecule that
the body is already using so it just
uses it like a normal type of a real
time in vivo imaging you get real-time
data from every patient you can perform
experiments faster and potentially
cheaper now currently this system is
very expensive but as this moves forward
[Music]
just like computer chips it'll get
cheaper and cheaper and cheaper the
critical point here is that it's
amenable to longitudinal clinical
studies and going back to high
definition medicine the longitudinal
clinical collection of data is going to
be critical in the cure of patients in
trying to get patients all the way
through treatment into
here you need the time points before
treatment following treatment and then
at treatment end so this is not
something that's novel it's been done
this is a UCSF and what you can see is
on the Left panel is benign prostate
tissue and you see the hyperpolarized
signal come up and where pyruvate is and
you can in the bottom panel and you can
see that the lactate which is the red
line there's not a lot of lactate being
produced here but you see the
hyperpolarized pyruvate pulse but not
any transition or metabolism to lactate
however in prostate cancer you start to
see lactate production and you can see
that in the top right hand panel where
pyruvate pink shows up and the lactate
peep shows up and then the bottom panel
you can see that pyruvate goes up
lactate starts to increase and then it
tails off with the pyruvate signal and
you can see this this image of a human
prostate where in the bottom right
corner where the two red arrows are
there is prostate cancer and you're
imaging that prostate cancer but the
benign tissue is not showing this
transition so it's a very dynamic and
you can visualize this and hopefully
this will be something that we might be
able this image will be linked to other
aspects of the disease and we're hoping
that we can fill in the DNA mutations
Asians things like that and help target
treatment along with this image
so the prostate cancer models that we're
using first off this is a kind of a
pharmacologic spiral and but you're
looking at some of the important drivers
of prostate cancer you have in the
initial diagnosis or at the the initial
part or the initial growth of prostate
cancer it's kind it's a DHT dependent
disease DHT is the steroid that drives
prostate differentiation in development
and it keeps the epithelial cell in its
lineage and it's epithelial lineage and
it keeps it doing its job however that
could kind of go wrong and you end up
with a DHT dependent cancer now this can
then be treated with castration and then
you see these cyclical loops as the
tumor begins to change over time and you
start to treat at these arrows you treat
for 17 you're treating for antigen
receptor then you treat for sark kinase
and these as these loops as the patient
goes through these loops you're giving
you see the expression of different
proteins and you're trying to treat them
according to the expression of these
proteins in the blue box you see that
you see that you get an oncogene
activation here you have a R oncogene
crosstalk microenvironment dependence
the tumor is beginning to change the
cancer is beginning to change and we're
hoping that we might be able to image
these spirals as we go through this
progression of the disease so you have a
R amplification and mutation paracrine
factors you now have other proteins
coming in fgfr C met a KT
and these are driving more of an AR
independent disease you exit from the
cycle and you're finally in an
aggressive more small cell type disease
very deadly so hopefully we can start
imaging and be able to pull these
distinct diseases apart and treat
specifically so that the patients get
the optimum benefit of treatment so the
Xena graphs that we have here we have a
number of Xena grass ones that we have
used in this study is the one three
three the one four four we use the one
five five and I think it was the one six
six
so one three three and the one three
three and the one six six have antigen
receptor the one five five and the one
four four do not have an urge and
receptor so serum PSA and the mice and
the one four four one five five you
don't see it but in the other two PDX as
you do C serum PSA this just tells you
that androgen receptor is driving one
disease and it's not in the other and
then some of these diseases will grow in
fast rate - others will not so here's
some relative protein levels in these PD
X's we have 133 which shows PSMA SIF 17
is expressed in ARS express now as you
go to the 144 there's no PMS a because
that's driven by androgen receptor
there's no antigen receptor expression
there's no PS PS ma you see a slight
amount of step 17 meaning that these
tumors can produce testosterone however
there's no AR so and in the other the
rest of these tumors we see some that
expressed smaller amounts of PSA some
under castration resistance or a
castration do not express PMS a even
though AR is there because the ligand is
not there to drive the air
an event so you can categorize these and
133 144 of 180 30 of the 163 and the 166
were developed and intact skid male mice
the 133 4 castrate the 144 13 castrate
the 118 30 castrator developed and
castrate skid mice so you have to wait
for these tumors to grow up after
castration
so androgen receptor variant is an
important part of the androgen signaling
axis especially in PD axes you'll see
lots of the variant this usually occurs
after castration and you can see that in
these two PDX models the 133 and the 180
as you see an intact there's just full
length they are but in castrate you
start to see some a rv7 expression and
in the 180 30 the intact there's a
little bit less AR there but when you
castrate air comes up in the air b7
signal is dramatically increase that is
in the right panel in the left panel it
just shows the RNA levels which Mir the
Western levels in the right panel
so castration you think that you may be
curing cancer but the cancer is so
dependent on AR that AR full-length they
are is overexpressed and AR v 7 is
expressed and the antigen signaling
continues even though you had treatment
[Music]
so this gives an idea of the expression
of AR and the non castrated is the left
panel to command a body and in turn
c-terminal antibody that picks up AR and
prostate cancer this is the 133 PD axe
and then after castration you wait two
or three weeks you can harvest the tumor
and again you see nuclear localized AR
so the antigen signaling axis very
strong in some of these tumors and even
after treatment with castration androgen
receptor signaling is continues so
that's spectrometry now we measured some
ligand levels during the treatment of
the 133 PDX and as you can see just
treating the tumor with with vehicle
each tumor will all of these animals
these mites are castrated each tumor
will make its own androgen it becomes
autonomous and this is what drives
progression of prostate cancer after
castration so you still see 230
nanograms per gram of testosterone in
these tumors and you see
dihydrotestosterone there - at about 400
nanograms per gram of tumor
if you treat with an inhibitor of 17
which is VT for 6 for this inhibitor is
blocked the lie ace activity of 617 said
17 is a bi functional enzyme it has a
hydraulic space activity analyze
activity the 4 6-4 molecule blocks the
lice activity but not the hydroxylase
activity and then pee
underneath it is abiraterone acetate
which is in the clinic right now but as
you can see
the amount of testosterone drops
dramatically with each treatment you get
around 60 to 70% inhibition
dihydrotestosterone also drops
dramatically it drops around 80 to 85%
in the bottom panel you'd black lines
the vehicle treated tumor growth over
time and then you have the VT four six
four in the red line and the AAA in the
blue line and you can see that both
treatments just slow the tumor growth
but they do not stop the tumor it's just
a suppression of the growth
it's another interesting thing is sub-17
inhibition we do see and this is by mass
spectrometry a steroid profile that
changed dramatically so in the vehicle
tree that mice cortisol in the tumor is
quite high and then progesterone is also
observed in the vehicle tumor and then
when you treat with abiraterone acetate
cortisol starts to disappear that's
because it blocks the hydroxylase
activity at 17
whereas progesterone begins to increase
and it's just all over the board
depending on each mouse there's a lot of
variability here but we can still
measure progesterone and it's about the
same as the vehicle although in some
cases that can increase dramatically
because as sub-17 is inhibited pregnant
alone increases and then that's
converted to progesterone by another
stereo genic enzyme in the tumor the
Beatty force explore the amount of
cortisol that is there decreases
slightly but this treatment is designed
to allow cortisol production so that you
don't have to give prednisone to
patients because of your - hypothalamus
pituitary axis getting off so it may be
used in the future we'll see
and then the progesterone levels are
very similar to vehicle and not quite as
dramatically impacted so here's a
hyperpolarization of one of the tumors
this is one eighty thirty this is an
androgen positive tumor and what you can
see is you can see the pyruvate peak
there in the middle this would be the
middle panel it's the middle peak the
transients the single transients taken
every two seconds so from the bottom to
the top you can see pyruvate pulse comes
in and then it decays over time and you
can see the lactate peak come up and the
aniline and carbo Co Co 3 heightens hco3
Pete come up but the lactate peak comes
up and then disappears and you can see
it on their side on the right panel
we've just shown one of the transients
for each of the tumors that we measure
so the top one is 133 the lactate Pete
seems to be a little bit bigger when any
30 lactates a little lower the 152
lactate is there but it's very low and
the one for 413 Peaks pyruvate is there
the lactate peak is very small on the
far left panel it's just an example of
kind of how the tumor looks according to
the end the imaging the how the MRI sees
the tumor and then we have to tell the
where the pixels are supposed to be so
you squish it down to where it's just
covering the tumor so hyperpolarized MRI
what we're looking at in these tumors is
were really concentrating on the
conversion of pyruvate to lactate this
is accomplished by an enzyme lactate
dehydrogenase now this this flux through
just one enzyme is actually impacted by
a number of proteins from glucose and
Porter all the way through glycolysis so
you get two pyruvate and then conversion
to lactate so what you're kind of
measuring is this flux of multiple
enzymes and transporters you're not
measuring just one enzyme so you have to
take that into consideration but you do
see in the right panel that when you
line up the AR positive tumors and this
is the lactate level that's measured by
hyperpolarization
compared to the energy receptor negative
tumors they are statistically different
and the amount of lactate produced in
the ar+
is a little bit higher than var negative
so what does this imply this implies
that maybe these tumors that are AR
positive get a little boost in
glycolysis whereas the tumors that are
AR negative
might have a little bit less glycolysis
so the prostate cancer PDX antigen
signaling you want to of course always
prove that your tumors that are a are
positive are being driven by
testosterone the tumors that are AR
negative they may have testosterone but
they don't have the protein so in the
left panel you see that we measure
testosterone by mass spectrometry units
around 200 to 250 picograms per gram of
tumor we also measure epi testosterone
the reason for this is that the mouse
model will make epi testosterone so we
want to make sure that we separate the
isobars get a good measurement of the
actual ligand that's driving AR
interesting interestingly 133 expresses
energy etc as we discussed before 144
does not however 144 has 617 and it does
seem to make some testosterone this is
an interesting aspect of these tumors
and it may be a way of the tumor to
impact its micro environment by
supplying testosterone multiple other
cells in the micro environment of these
tumors can respond to energy receptor
signaling so you may share ligand
between endothelial cells and
the source of the ligand the cancer so
we measured a few bioenergy
intermediates we actually measured quite
a few but we've limited I've limited
that in this talk but the point of this
is to demonstrate that in the left-hand
panel you see more aniline and lactate
produce in the 133 androgen receptor
positive tumor then you do in the
antigen negative tumor the 144 tumor you
also see more succinate in the lactate
or in the ar+ tumor than in the AR
negative tumor and this is by NMR and
then what we did is you want to use
usually want to try to use two
analytical instruments to show the same
ratios or the similar ratios of what
you're measuring with one out I'm one
out of a political instrument so the M
the NMR is giving us this data and then
we do mass spectrometry and we see the
similar trends where succinate is high
in the AR positive it's lower and the AR
negative and lactate is higher in the AR
positive and lower in the AR negative so
it's important to have this confirmation
using two different analytical
instruments demonstrating that lactate
is produced in the ar+ tumor at a higher
rate than in the left that in the AR
negative two
[Music]
so here are some other intermediates or
bioenergy intermediates and in this
panel what we did is we took the 133
tumor in the intact animal and measured
these analytes and we also measured it
in the castrate animal so yep mice that
are have the 133 tumor you castrate one
group of mice and you leave the other
group of mice intact and we followed the
differences and interestingly you see
that by NMR of the femur eight levels
are the same lactate is the same certain
eights the same Adaline is slightly
different but regardless of the removal
of ligand the antigen signaling is still
there and we can demonstrate this by NMR
and by mass spec so that the trends are
the same you see that in intact animals
and castrate animals the six and eight
levels are the same the lactate levels
are the same and the Fuma rate levels
are the same now quantitatively we can't
cross over but the point of this is to
note the trends the trends are the same
so we have high confidence that what
we're measuring is actually what we're
seeing in these tumors androgen receptor
is still driving signaling in these
tumors regardless of loss of ligand
[Music]
so the way we're going to implement in
that this in a clinical trial is we're
going to have randomization of two to
one
this will be performed by the
oncologists in our department
we'll have a baseline image
prior to randomization there will be an
in-house biopsy that's optional optional
depending on the patient some patients
will allow biopsies others won't we may
have biopsies throughout the stop the
study and then it's a two to one
randomization group a abiraterone
acetate air and 509 cortisol replacement
and chemical castration group be it will
be chemical castration and air and 509 a
art blocker so we will take these images
at baseline three weeks three months and
at six months and then after six months
the patients will always be
prostatectomy and biopsies will be
performed and tissue distributed and we
will be looking at morphology molecular
aspects protein steroid bioenergy we'll
do some RNA maybe even some RNA seek so
this is the proposed trial
the workflow that we have is the
patients will come in they'll have
hyperpolarized MRI will be doing in
parallel PD X's PD X's that are from
localized high risk not the PD X as I
described as another set of PD X's
they'll go through treatment
they'll be prostatectomy the PD X will
be harvested the clinical data will be
collected NMR data will be collected
lcms data collected IHC data all of this
data will be put into bioinformatics and
we'll try to pull apart groups based on
principal component analysis and other
statistical tests to demonstrate
responders versus non responders
hopefully this will allow us to link all
of the data analysis we have with
hyperpolarized imaging so in the future
patients coming in being imaged will
take some blood and hopefully we can
discriminate and Buckett certain people
into certain treatments that's the goal
so this is a large group of people
multiple other people are involved in
this but GU Mehta is led by dr.
Logothetis
we have other clinicians myself and
other researchers including pathology
and other cores all involved in this
project we also have cancer systems
imaging doctor penico worms as the lead
there multiple faculty members involved
in this this is a project that's
required a lot of expertise and we're
trying to kind of bring two departments
to a clinical and a hardcore kind of
imaging department together and Link the
information
the data to improve treatment of
prostate cancer patients I appreciate
your time I'm happy to answer any
questions
Thank You dr. Titus for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
dr. Titus will answer as many questions
as time permits the first question is
what is the feasibility of high
definition medicine so this is this is
uh this is more like a thought
experiment where high definition
medicine they're working out details by
thinking about it and making proposals
this is not something that at this point
is ready to implement but the idea I
think is strong and it's there and
hopefully as this idea is disseminated
and people accepted it we can start
collecting data and we will reach
billions of patients and have data on
that number of patients where where
you'll have a tremendous statistical
analysis to help in getting patients the
optimal treatment and benefit
[Music]
hyperpolarized modules are currently
limited and hyperpolarized MRI is
limited to single molecule so how much
information will hyper pol
hyperpolarized image regional so this is
a good question because what we have is
we're just this is just pyruvate to
lactate transition
but a number of molecules can be
hyperpolarized succinate is another but
we hope that in the future chemists will
be able to come up and we might be able
to derivative some molecules and
hyperpolarize a derivatized molecule
that will continue to be cycled through
say the TCA cycle or cycled through
pentose phosphate pathway or cycled
through nucleic acid metabolism or
biosynthesis and we'll be able to
monitor these other pathways it's in an
image by imaging them with
hyperpolarized MRI so you can imagine
the possibilities here that you could
have a number of imaging events all
within the space of maybe an hour for
each patient and get a number of
interesting data sets that can then be
incorporated in high definition medicine
I would like to once again thank dr.
Titus for his presentation do you have
any final comments um well no so I I
guess I hope this is kind of an
introduction to high definition medicine
how imaging is progressing in the clinic
and how we're trying to use
patient-derived xenograft
as a proof of concept that we can
actually use hyperpolarized imaging to
distinguish patients and we will
continue to work on this and we hope
that in the future the clinical trial
and the other PD axes as we collect data
on them will will benefit patients and
benefit their therapy thanks again and
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by email after the webinar we
also like to thank our sponsor agilent
technologies for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webinar has
been approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
June 2018 lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay and
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
[Music]